good afternoon and welcome to Days
Downing Street press conference I'm
pleased to be joined today by Professor
Jonathan van tan let me start by
updating you on the latest information
from the government's Cobra data file I
can report through the government's
monitoring and testing program as of
today one million seven hundred and
twenty eight thousand four hundred and
forty-three tests for coronavirus had
now been carried out in the UK including
ninety six thousand eight hundred and
seventy eight tests yesterday two
hundred and fifteen thousand two hundred
and sixty people have been tested
positive that's an increase of three
thousand eight hundred and ninety six
cases since yesterday eleven thousand
eight hundred nine people are currently
in hospital with corona virus in the UK
down from twelve thousand two hundred
and eighty four yesterday and 17 percent
down since the last day last week same
day last week and tragically thirty one
thousand five hundred and eighty seven
people have now died that's an increase
of 346 fatalities in all settings since
yesterday these deaths are devastating
for the families friends victims and our
thoughts and our prayers are with all
over them every day
they're also strengthened our resolve to
fight the pandemic with all the
resources we can muster in the weeks
ahead tomorrow the Prime Minister set
out a roadmap for the next phase in our
strategy to tackle current virus in
support of this today I'm setting out an
ambitious programme to help prepare our
transport network for the critical role
it will play as we emerge from this
crisis importantly it is true to say
that moving beyond kovat will be a
gradual process not a single leap to
freedom so when we do emerge the world
will seem quite different at least for
some time the need to maintain social
distancing means that our public
transport system cannot go back to where
it left off and here is a very stark
fact
even with public transport reverting to
a full service once you take him to
account the to metered social distancing
rule there would only be effective
capacity for one in ten passengers in
many parts of our network just a tenth
of the old capacity so getting Britain
moving again while not overcrowding or
transport network is going to require
many of us to think very carefully about
how and when we travel we've
accomplished so much over the past seven
weeks of this lockdown the whole country
has been responsible for reducing kovat
reproduction or the our rate millions of
households across the UK have changed
their behavior for the greater good
getting Britain moving again whilst not
overcrowding our transport network
represents an another another enormous
logistical challenge yes this is a
problem which presents a health
opportunity - an opportunity to make
lasting changes that could not only make
us fitter but also better off both
mentally and physically
in the long run during the crisis
millions of people millions of people
have discovered the benefits of active
travel bicycling or walking many have
been able to appreciate this remarkably
warm summer a sorry spring whilst
sticking to the guidelines in some
places there's been a 70 percent rise in
the number of people on bikes whether
that's for exercise and all necessary
journeys like stocking up on food so
whilst it's crucial that we stay at home
when the country does get back to work
we need to ask those people to carry on
cycling walking and for them to be
joined by many other as well otherwise
with public transport capacity severely
restricted more cars could be drawn to
the roads or towns and cities and they
would quickly become gridlocked we also
know that in this new world pedestrians
will need more space so today I'm
announcing a 2 billion pound package to
put cycling and walking at the heart of
our transport policy to set out how we
deliver this will bring forward a
national cycling plan for publication in
early June
in line with the statute recycle and
walking investment strategy to help
double cycling and increase walking by
2025 the first stage worth 250 million
pounds is a series of swift emergency
interventions to make cycling and
walking safer pop-up bike lanes wider
pavements cycle and bus only streets all
examples of what people will start to
see more of accompanying the new money
where are we are today polishing
fast-track statutory guidance effective
immediately requiring councils in
England to cater for significantly
increased numbers of cyclists and
pedestrians are making it easier for
them to create safe icy streets for
employees who want to start to cycle to
work but don't have a bike right now the
popular cycle to work scheme already
allows employees to say between 25 and
39 percent of the cost of a new bike or
indeed electric bike there's been a huge
increase in people using this scheme and
will work with employers to increase
uptake even further and for those who
may have an old bike perhaps in the shed
and want to get it back to a work
roadworthy condition there'll be a
voucher scheme for bike repairs and for
maintenance plans are also being
developed to boost bike fixing
facilities across the country what's
more over the next few months we'll set
out further measures to make a
once-in-a-generation change to the way
that people travel in Britain this will
include tough new standards for cycling
infrastructure a new national cycling
champion to inspire us much closer links
to the NHS with GPS prescribing cycling
to help get us fitter legal changes to
protect vulnerable road users at least
one zero-emission City with its centre
restricted to bikes and electric
vehicles only and the creation of
long-term cycling programme and budgets
just like we have already for our roads
there's clear evidence not least from
the time that the Prime Minister was
Mayor of London that making the streets
safe for walking and cycling is good for
retailers good for business and very
healthy for the economy and in making
these changes on that
recovery can also become a green
recovery as a result one of the few
positive benefits of this crisis is
drastically better air quality the
health benefits that that brings more
than 20,000 extra deaths a year in the
UK are attributed to nitrogen dioxide
emissions we want to try to preserve
this cleaner air so today I'm also fast
tracking trials of East scooters
bringing this program already underway
from next year forward to next month and
extending those trials to fall from four
local authorities to every region in the
country that wants them in a bid to get
a scooter rental schemes up and running
in cities as fast as possible
helping reduce car use on shorter
journeys and taking taking some of the
pressure off the buses at this vital
time these trials will help us assess
the safety benefits together with their
impact on public spaces now we know that
the car industry has of course been very
badly hit during this crisis but April's
new sales figures showed us that for the
first time ever that the two biggest
selling models were both electric
vehicles so to keep this quiet clean car
revolution going
I can also announce today ten million
pounds of additional support for car
charging points on our streets the car
will remain the mainstay for many
families as well as as backing the
electric infrastructure therefore we're
also going to accelerate the filling of
potholes that plague so many road users
in all the forms and just as new
technology as change in the vehicles we
use so digital technology will help us
to be more informed about the choices we
make to battle against kovat at a time
when transport demand could quickly
become overwhelmed the capacity not
being there when there we need urgent
access to real-time travel information
it is crucial that we take advantage of
the UK's digital expertise therefore
with the right mobile apps people can
find out which parts of the transport
network are overcrowded and avoid them
they can choose alternative travel
options to help maintain safe distancing
all
can get information to help stagger
their journeys and lift the burden on
public transport at peak times so this
week I chaired a roundtable with key
players like Google Microsoft and
British firm city mapper to develop both
data and apps to help the public view
crowding across the transport network
and in real-time this two billion pound
announcement represents the most
significant package of cycling walking
in green travel by any British
government clearly it will never be
possible to cycle walk or even a scooter
everywhere cars will remain an
absolutely vital form of transport to
many and so in the coming days oh and as
we look to the future that we've further
announcements about the huge investments
were making in roads and in rail taking
advantage of the low usership during
this kovat crisis finally as we begin
the process of preparing public
transport to get Britain moving again no
one should underestimate the sheer scale
of the challenge ahead even when every
train bus and tram fully restored to
service this will not be enough social
distancing measures mean that everyone
who travels will need to contribute to
meeting this capacity challenge changing
our behavior is the single biggest thing
that's beaten back this virus the
Welcome fool we've seen deaths is not
only achievement of the doctors and
nurses and care workers but everyone in
the country for following the stay at
home guidance to reiterate nothing I'm
saying today changes these basic rules
but as we contemplate the future we will
have to carry on making changes
particularly after we leave our homes
preventing overcrowding which could lead
to a second spike and more deaths will
be the responsibility of each and every
one of us so please only travel when you
need to be considerate to others and
help prioritize essential workers and
let's all play our part in ensuring that
we're able to get Britain moving safely
again when that time comes I'd like to
now turn to Professor Jonathan Venter